a candlelight vigil was held for a life
lost far too soon today would have been
nathan valencia's 21st birthday he died
suddenly after a charity boxing match
for unlv fraternity victoria saha was
there tonight and joins us after
speaking with those closest to him
victoria
[Music]
sasha the candles are still burning here
from the vigil the alumni amphitheater
was filled with those who knew valencia
the most they shared memories which
included some tears and some giggles on
a day he was looking forward to for a
while
on what would have been nathan
valencia's 21st birthday candles weren't
blown out instead they were lit to honor
him i know that today for his birthday
he wanted to celebrate with all of his
closest friends lacey foster was
valencia's girlfriend of almost two
years my life is now a celebration of
yours valencia wanted to represent his
fraternity sigma alpha epsilon in a
charity boxing match event held by kappa
sigma fraternity on november 19th he
passed away four days later from brain
injuries foster was in the crowd she
says there weren't any medical
professionals on site
after he came over to me and like i
looked like he looked in my eyes and it
was just kind of something that you knew
something was wrong and he needed actual
like medical attention the president of
sigma alpha epsilon fraternity says
valencia was always selfless and since
the boxing match was for charity it
motivated him even more to put himself
in the ring in my opinion philanthropies
are the best part of being a fraternity
and sorority but
it was just i feel like it was just very
unorganized so
there needs to be more accountability
with you know being
kept assembling as they wait for
accountability to be taken valencia's
friends and family will continue to
remember the boy who loved to share
laughs with everyone around him
the lawyers representing valencia's
family were present tonight they echoed
the same thing they want someone to take
accountability so this tragedy does not
happen again unlv also released a
statement they said that they were
looking into this incident we'll have
that we do have that full statement up
at our website at 8newsnow.com metro
police is also investigating this
reporting from the unlv campus tonight
victoria saha live local now